hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem top 5
minecraft mods video bald wie ich finde
das ist nämlich meine meinung wie ich
finde
die fünf besten mods die euer spiel am
meisten bereichern die die coolsten
sachen hinzufügen die coole features
haben die vielleicht jetzt teile darf
also ein paar mods davon sind wirklich
so wie man sich zu denken
coole sachen hinzugefügt werden sind
revolutionäre ein paar andere sachen
sind eher so von notz also ich möchte
euch einfach die fünf mods vorstellen
die ich am coolsten finde das cool oder
beste immer zusammen also ein passendes
wort dafür & partners adjektiv und ich
würde sagen ich stellt ihr euch jetzt
mal nach und nach vorn wir fangen an mit
platz fünf den fünften platz beim einer
rangliste belegt nämlich die too much
team themen und welche ich selber einmal
vorgestellt habt da seht ihr gerade
videos eingeblendet aus der review
findet übrigens auch die reviews und
links den ganzen ort und in der
beschreibung dass ich dieselbe
runterladen können weil ich wollte jetzt
nicht alle im game vorstellen sondern
eher so ein paar bilder zeigen so ein
paar videoausschnitt und das ganze dann
so ein bisschen cooler bearbeiten
also was macht die tun hat stehen thema
die tun hat stehen neben themen mod
macht schon wie der name es sagt zuviel
tnt also zu deutsch übersetzt also nicht
zu viel sondern es gibt sehr sehr viele
neue bomben möglichkeiten zu pumpen
möglichkeiten sind da gegeben und zwar
kann man beispielsweise mit einem haus
tnt kann man häuser so herb bomben also
dann werden häuser gebaut mit ocean tnt
kann man ozeane kreieren mit web apps
kann man diese ozeane wieder wegmachen
dann gibt es mining bons mit denen man
riesige flächen aushöhlen kann und dann
werden direkt schon fackeln gesetzt die
sind super für untergrund arbeiten also
für höhen arbeiten dinge im untergrund
unter der erde auf jeden fall wo es
dunkel ist weil an direkter fackeln
gesetzt werden
dann gibt es noch ganz andere bomben wie
zum beispiel eine flat baum und noch
ganz ganz viele andere sachen
ich blende euch gerade im hintergrund
schon so ein paar ausschnitte von le
mans teil findet ein link und in der
beschreibung das war platz fünf und
jetzt komm platz vier
platz nummer 4 wird in einer rangliste
von der marvel kraft modifikation belegt
dass es eine mod die euch bestimmt der
helden aus der an aus dem marvel filmen
hinzufügt also marvel ist es ja diese
filmstudio sie da mal wie ein halb tor
es bei dem ein paar andere sachen es
werden auf jeden fall ja wie schon
gesagt superhelden hinzugefügt wie
beispielsweise ein mann der durch die
luft fliegen kann
ich weiß ja auch superman dabei ist aber
auf jeden fall ist er dabei mit seinem
tor hat er damit blitze machen kann dann
ist links dabei ist beim ndr mit
spinnennetzen durch die stadt fliegen
kann
dann sind auch einfach ganz normale
leute dabei und es werden neue items
hinzugefügt wie waffen oder all dieser
thalhammer mit dem man sachen machen
kann und jeder held von den hat
bestimmte fähigkeiten einsetzen kann
könnt ihr selbst herausfinden link ist
in der beschreibung bilder wurden euch
gerade eingeblendet jetzt auch ein paar
videos dazu und das ganze seht hier
gerade im hintergrund das ist auf jeden
fall meinen platz vier das ist die
marvel kraft modifikation platz nummer
drei belegt bei mir opti feind zu ob die
feinen kann ich euch jetzt quasi nur so
ein paar screenshots zeigen was für
einstellungen und damit vornehmen kann
und dass man damit zoomen kann in
minecraft wenn die steuerung gedrückt
haltet euer kann welche taste als selbst
verpflegen
was ob die feier an sich macht falls ihr
ob die fein wirklich nicht kennen sollte
sollte eigentlich jeder kennen
falls es nicht kann sollte ich möchte
auch noch einmal ganz kurz erklären was
diese mod hinzufügt und zwar ist es
quasi mit euro das vom in stuttgart
unter gefallen es ist es quasi die
standard modifikation die nahezu jeder
minecraft einfach haben sollte denn ob
die fein macht eure minecraft doppelt so
schnell
das heißt nicht dass die geschwindigkeit
hoch gestellt wird sondern einfach dass
die frames per second hof gewinne
hochgesetzt werden also dass das ganze
flüssiger läuft das chance schneller
geladen werden dass man zoomen kann dass
man sagen kann okay er soll so und
soviel chance pro minute lagen oder so
und so viel man kann ein stopp wolken
generiert werden ob bäume die grafik gut
sein soll ob das wasser schwimmen soll
oder nicht
macht sein soll so ganz ganz viele
verschiedene sachen kann man da auf
jeden fall einstellen sind möglich
dadurch einzustellen
man kann damit auch unter anderem zoomen
und das sind ganz ganz viele sachen die
eure minecraft einfach viel viel besser
machen von grund auf eigentlich ein
standard modifikation die auf jeden fall
haben solltet linke es in der
beschreibung und jetzt gehts weiter mit
platz zwei platz nummer 2 wird von einer
modifikation belegt die ich ebenfalls
damals mal vorgestellt habe einen link
zu dem video zu dem ganzen video mit ton
et cetera ist wieder und in der
beschreibung
es ist nämlich die internet modifikation
beziehungsweise web modification findet
auf jeden fall linken der beschreibung
wenn ihr euch das einfach downloaden
jedenfalls kann man damit wirklich in
minecraft ins internet gehen man kann
sich so ein risiken pc bauen man kann
sich eine fernbedienung machen kann sich
auch ein ipad bauen und dann kann man
auf bestimmte webseiten gehen und zwar
auf alle die man möchte ich bin sogar in
dem video auf meinen eigenen
youtube-kanal gegangen und konnte mir
meine eigenen videos in minecraft
anschauen
ich weiß nicht ob das ganze mittlerweile
auch auf servern verfügbar ist weil dann
könnte man einfach auf einem microsoft
server einen live stream zum beispiel
laufen lassen von einer anderen person
die gerade auf dem server ist und man
kann dann auch live auf dem server seien
während diese andere person auf diesem
server spielt und stream kann man kann
sich auf dem server auf einer leinwand
anschauen dass diese person live macht
in dem game mode das wären extrem coole
dinge die damit gemacht werden könnten
wenn das ganze für multiplayer verfügbar
ist man kann auf jeden fall damit in
minecraft ins internet gehen und auch
die ganze website dann auf dem ipad
bestaunen unterwegs et cetera ist
richtig richtig cool kann ich euch nur
ans herz legen und das waren
modifikationen nummer zwei und jetzt
kommen wir zu platz eins
platz nummer eins in meiner top 5 motzt
rangliste ist die vlans modifikation
welche sowas von viele sachen hinzufügt
die vlans modifikation ist für mich die
allerbeste motti je gemacht wurde ich
hab noch keine rigider zu hoch geladen
weil sie mir viel zu umfangreich ist
wird eventuell bald noch kommen diese
review würde dann allerdings denke ich
locker 40 minuten lang gehen da
beispielsweise unmengen an flugzeugen
und fahrzeugen allgemeine zugefügt
werden da gibt's panzer da gibt's
düsenjets da gibt's jumbo airline
flugzeuge ganz viele sachen dann werden
sachen hinzugefügt wie auch falsch
zum beispiel man kann das flugzeug
springen mit fallschirmen runter es
werden waffen hinzugefügt mit dem mann
um sich herum schießen kann ganz viele
waffen es gibt eine p90 es gibt sniper
rifles rifles es gibt eine ak-47 es gibt
ne berit es gibt eine magnum es gibt
ganz ganz viele sachen auf jeden fall an
waffen hinzugefügt werden
es werden roboter hinzugefügt große
maschinen wie bei was gibt sender für
spiele die ich euch mal sagen kann oder
filmen wie zb bei transformers diese
großen maschinen so ähnlich werden
zugefügt man kann sich dort selbst
einsetzt um sich herum ballern alle
möglichen sachen denn da zugefügt und
das aller geiz ist es funktioniert im
multiplayer das heißt es gibt server
beispielsweise sogenannte call of duty
server wo vlans modifikationen drauf
sind man kann sich dann waffen kräften
um sich herum schießen alles mögliche in
minecraft machen
das ist auf jeden fall die top 1
modifikation der link ist zu allem aus
und in der beschreibung wenn euch solche
videos gefallen also meine persönliche
ansicht auf dinge wie beispielsweise
modifikation eventuell macht das auch
noch mal zu textchat packs einfach dinge
die ich am besten finde weil ich denke
wenn ihr auf meinen kanal abonniert habe
liegt ja das was ich mache und eventuell
auch das was mir gefällt gefällt euch
auch deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
mach das mal wenn es euch gefallen hat
zeigt es mir auf jeden fall mit einem
mag ich also wenn ihr mehr davon wollte
schreibst du dann auch mal die
kommentare und dann mache ich davon
eventuell noch mal war